Abortion is an extremely contentious issue
for many people in the U.S. and around the
world, many of whom want to see a world with
few abortions.
Luckily, science is on the case.
Hey there countrywomen and countrymen, Trace
here for DNews.
Near the end of January, President Trump signed
an Executive Order reinstating something called
the “Mexico City Policy,” or “Global
Gag Rule,” blocking U.S. foreign aid to
any organization performing, advising on,
or endorsing abortion as a method of family
planning.
It was first signed by former President Reagan.
Depending on the administration, the rule
comes and goes.
Dispassionate data exists to try to understand
how to the decrease abortion rates, and restricting
access to abortion, counseling, and advisory
services doesn’t decrease the number of
abortions performed, but does the opposite!
A study by the World Health Organization,
looked at over 260-thousand women in 20 countries
from 1994 to 2008, and found once the Mexico
City Policy was reinstated the last time,
in 2001, the abortion rate more than doubled.
They even created an algorithm to compare
those with and without exposure to abortion
advice, endorsement or services, and those
without access had more abortions.
And this isn’t just worldwide, it’s also
in the United States.
A study published in Perspectives on Sexual
and Reproductive Health examined abortions
in the United States, and found from 2011
to 2014, the rate dropped by 12 percent.
Their study wanted to find out what caused
this huge drop.
They looked at access to abortions and contraception
and also the closing of abortion clinics.
They didn’t find a strong correlation between
closing clinics and decreasing rates.
But, did think a decrease in unintended pregnancies
and increase in contraceptive use contributed
to the decline in abortions.
The U.S. currently has the lowest abortion
rate since it became legal in 1973, and yet
people are still denying sexual health education
works.
This study postulates that both contraception
and education are at play.
Though they say more research is obviously
needed.
Many believe unintended pregnancies are a
result of contraception failure, but according
to a report by the Guttmacher Institute, a
sexual health research nonprofit… that would
only account for 5 percent of all unintended
pregnancies.
Of the remaining 95 percent: most was from
non-use of contraception, and a bit less than
half was incorrect or inconsistent use.
This means a big chunk of our unintended pregnancy
problem is likely a lack of education!
A study in Plos ONE echos this sentiment:
with findings so strong they put them in the
subtitle, saying “Why We Need Comprehensive
Sex Education in the U.S.”
Though, access and education don’t work
if people don’t accept them as options to
countering unintended pregnancies.
According to a study done over 8 years published
in the Archives of Pediatrics & Adolescent
Medicine, more contraception instruction,
and education, correlated with lower rates
of 15 to 17 year old’s getting pregnant
-- what we call teen pregnancy.
And there are proven methods to purely decrease
abortion rates.
A 2012 study published in Obstetrics & Gynecology
followed over 9000 girls and women, and reported
teen birth rates dropped by 82 percent, and
abortions dropped by approximately two-thirds...when
they did this one crazy thing... gave them
free birth control access.
Unintended pregnancies aren’t just something
we can write off with the flourish of a pen.
A Studies in Family Planning paper, reported
40 percent of all pregnancies worldwide were
unintended in 2012; half ended in abortion,
but 38 percent resulted in unplanned births.
Those unplanned births affect the lives of
everyone involved forever -- mothers, children,
fathers, grandparents, social support networks,
et cetera.
According to a 1988 study in Family Planning
Perspectives, three-quarters of women seeking
abortions said, “having a baby would interfere
with work, school or other responsibilities,”
about two-thirds “could not afford” a
child, and half “did not want to be a single
parent or had relationship problems.”
Some women stated they weren’t mature enough
to have a child, and some still said their
parents wished them to abort.
Clearly, unintended pregnancies will continue
to happen if we do nothing.
And, according to dozens of studies, abortion
rates decline when people have access to contraception
and the education to use it properly.
Though there are many who have politicized
this issue, the data seems to indicate that
restricting access for political reasons might
cause more unintended pregnancies, and thus,
actually increase the rates of abortion.
Still curious about abortions?
Do you know how they work?
There is more than one kind, and we’ve got
each process explained, here.
How do you feel about the U.S. having the
lowest abortion rate in a long time?
Let us know in the comments, please subscribe
for more DNews and thanks for watching.